one you gotta radically believe in what
it is that you do most people are just
trying I think I should do this because
someone says I speak well everything
that comes out of my mouth it's not
something that I'm trying to do to see
if people will like it I'm not trying to
have a conversation and think well what
if they don't like it there's nothing
that comes out of my mouth every word I
believe wholeheartedly that this is what
I'm here to do is bring people back to
themselves through their inner child and
teach them how to remember the parts of
them that they haven't yet given a voice
and I'm so clear on that because I'm so
clear how you do anything is how you do
everything there's not a shred of doubt
in my mind so before I even go into
thinking that I want to coach somebody
either I'm coaching people through the
energy of my insecurities or lack of
belief and not being worthy or I'm
coaching people to a specific Direction
based off of something that they
actually want that's first before there
any kind of coaching anything
foreign
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us Movie Makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip oh my goodness it's good to see you
brother it's great to see you King why
don't we start uh with the advice that I
gave you like let's go to the punch line
of the advice I gave you and you
implemented it and got some incredible
results because I've given some similar
advice to the members here and then
we'll backtrack to like the story and
how you got in the coaching and and all
of that as well I would say I started a
new business and I was already doing
well but like my business was
like I had no like Direction
and I started this whole new thing it
was it was called the artist power the
artist is the little kid inside of you
before life Stripped Away Your Passion
your creativity your energy and
everything and when you tap into that
energy that original authentic energy
from when you were a kid it unlocks a
power
that is that's what I call artist power
and that's the name of my company artist
power and I had this idea the same magic
the same genius the Same Love For
Humanity one of them like my main why is
to bring people back home to themselves
so many people are struggling and doing
things that deep down inside they don't
really want to do but they need to feed
the family their mom told them to do
this their dad told them to do this so
my deep why of bringing people back home
to themselves their most authentic State
it's always been so powerful and magical
thing about it was I didn't have
Direction
and I was at an event Evan and I are
part of the the similar this um
marketing and it's like a mastermind
slash mentorship slash networking genius
Network and he just looked at me and he
was like the world needs to see Garen
Jones you know how Evan is he's like the
world needs to see guarantula I've never
seen him not smile and I'm like yep you
know I've heard that before he was like
what is it that he was doing this talk
on YouTube he was like what is it that
you're selling and I was like man I
coach people I can coach people on the
spot and literally cause a radical
change in their life or some type of uh
perspective shift whether it's on Zoom
whether it's in person whether it's my
masterminds leadership programs
definitely my Retreats and he was like
well there's nothing online
that shows that value that you do
he was like so instead of posting seven
ways to success or three ways to get out
of I don't know just get out of hell and
come into your own Heaven whatever he's
like instead of doing that
post and let people see the value of you
being an awesome coach and I was already
doing that but I was just like
unconsciously doing it I wasn't I didn't
give it focused I didn't give it
attention like when I'm coaching
somebody in a hot seat one on one and
they're like well I'm struggling with
this and that you know I'm struggling
that instantly I can coach them give
them a hot seat give them a perspective
shift and within three minutes something
inside of them can shift and change
and I told him I said nothing online
represents who I really am in person and
what I really do and the magic that I
really offer for Humanity he was like
well that's the stuff that you show on
YouTube that's the stuff that you show
on Instagram
and something inside of me said Garen
stop and listen
and that's where the student
the student in me not the one who's
inspired millions of people the one that
says Garen pretend like you know nothing
in this moment
you're a baby you literally know nothing
and you're hearing this for the first
time
and I stopped and I said okay
I'm gonna just start
sharing visuals
of my coaching
and what I have to offer and that's what
I'm gonna do at that time I only had two
people signed up for my retreat my
retreat was five thousand dollars
I only had two people signed up for my
retreat
when Evan said that to me
I
then went on Instagram live and I just
typed in free coaching
and then people got on and I told them
why I was doing free coaching and this
is my my offer and my give you know I'd
be either really expensive or I'm really
free and I was like right now you want
to take a full advantage of really free
because I'm putting millions of dollars
worth of experience in years over a
decade of experience of coaching leading
leaders and and building uh communities
and thing I'm putting all of this into
the opportunity for you to ask that your
burning desired question
I'm doing like 10 coaching things at on
in one sitting for like two hours three
minutes three minutes three minutes
three minutes just sharing the value and
then taking that video and then just
leaving it online for people to see the
coaching well I was pitching my retreat
the entire time
in two weeks
so for a whole month I only had two
people for my retreat
after Evan shared that with me in two
weeks I had 55 people
so just imagine two weeks five thousand
five thousand five thousand five
thousand five thousand five thousand and
then over a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
literally in two weeks from that one
conversation
and then someone will say well Garen
that's easy for you to say you have a
lot of followers okay well let's just
take my friend uh Kyra Poulson who
doesn't have a lot of followers compared
to me but it's a lot of followers
compared to her I shared with her the
exact same thing she was like how did
you sell out your retreat it's like I
still got to fill out this thing
what I did is I I I paid it Forward I
shared with Kira the exact same thing
that Evan shared with me and she was
like oh my God Garen
it happened and it worked if you look at
her Instagram
freaking
seven months ago it was a dud compared
to the to the magician that she really
is it none of it represent who she
really was and I had the same
conversation she was like oh my God I
sold out my retreat thank you so much so
a seed that Evan gave to me again all I
did was like doesn't belong to me and
all I did was pass on that information
and now it's I'm sharing this with my
whole community and I'm watching it
Blossom through so many people well let
me show you what what has happened since
then I still took that same thing I sold
out that Retreat and then at that
Retreat my upsell was my Mastermind and
another Retreat which I doubled the
price
and then added some more things that
first Retreat I grossed 100 a hundred
and seventy thousand dollars between the
Mastermind and the retreat which was
literally two months later
735 thousand dollars so listen this
happened
this happened within two months
well then I had another Retreat and then
another high level leadership program
which is going on right now and the the
offering was fifteen thousand twenty
five thousand and forty thousand
and 10 people got the 40 000 offer
because they already had the VA they saw
the value and when they see that the
value is much more than the offer
they'll people will spend more on value
than they will the product 10 people got
the 40 000 offer within 20 minutes so
I'm literally looking I'm like yo what
the fudge I am so let's freaking go
So within four months
brand new company
three people in my company
grossed over seven figures and I wasn't
trying to even do that I wasn't even
trying to do that
I had a deep desire I have a deep desire
to bring people back home to themselves
and because I had the gifts that I
already have and you have the gifts that
you already have it just needed a
container and a direction and people
need to see exactly what you do not hear
what you do see it with their own eyes
like see you coaching somebody in real
time so you're doing something in real
time whatever your offer is
and so I took what Evan gave me and it
turned it into an entire forest and was
able to feed my family and also am now
teaching
this is a part of my teaching and the
coaching and Leadership that I already
had I just added this tool and now we're
looking at you know the companies at
1.79 million and it's been at the very
first offer was June
that first retreat was in June and now
we're here and I don't share with you
this to like impress you but to press
upon you
what could happen when you dial in lock
in take your natural genius that all of
you have
put it into a container give it
Direction and share it for the world to
be able to see what it is that you do
not what it is that you talk about you
in action
doing
what you do
Evan that's what you supported me in
thank you so much dude I love it and and
man congratulations on on everything you
deserve it dude you deserve the wins and
all the flowers and the impact and you
could see in your eyes you know when you
give Garen a little bit of feedback
you see the you see the light bulb
moment kind of switch on he's like oh I
got that I'm gonna go get me mine let's
go and then the thing with you too
though is like you don't just create a
forest you then create like the forest
for others yes you know which is which
is beautiful this group is called
movement makers everybody's on a path to
build a movement and a lot of people
here are currently coaches or our
aspirations to have a coaching business
what are maybe some of the Practical
tips advice you know beyond the stuff I
gave you what have you learned on your
own on this journey that could help them
build their coaching practice build
their coaching practice or build a move
start coaching practice and then go
movement one you gotta radically believe
in what it is that you do most people
are just trying I think I should do this
because someone says I speak well and
something I want to share is
everything that comes out of my mouth
it's not something that I'm trying to do
to see if people will like it
I'm not trying to have a conversation
and think well what if they don't like
it there's nothing that comes out of my
mouth every word the even the pauses
even the breaths everything I believe
wholeheartedly
that this is what I'm here to do
is bring people
back to themselves through their inner
child and teach them how to remember the
parts of them that they haven't yet
given a voice
and I'm so clear on that because I'm so
clear
how you do anything is how you do
everything there's not a shred of doubt
in my mind
so before I even go into thinking that I
want to coach somebody either I'm
coaching people
through the energy of my insecurities or
lack of belief
are on or am I not being worthy or I'm
coaching people
to a specific Direction based off of
something that they actually want
that's first before there's any kind of
coaching anything
I am so clear
so clarity
in what you're going to be coaching
people on
before you like
try your hand in it because
the soul of a person will always know
when you're trying
always
they'll know when you're fluffing
they they'll know even even when I
didn't I didn't have all of this my
belief my belief in myself
and my belief that I I know I have
something to offer
now that will make me look good
but something that would lift that would
lift people or something that will add
value to people
so number one is clarity
number two what is your great value
offer
number three is knowing what they want
I had a friend
she was like Karen I can't get any sales
and you know and I'm this coach and I'm
this Apothecary coach which Apothecary
is great and you know every time she
would try to explain it it became like
this 15 minute explanation
of the kind of Coach she was and the
first time and I was like wow that's
really amazing and half the words that
she was saying I had to look up in a
dictionary and I have I I have a great
understanding when it comes to words and
language and communication and then
after other people were asking what do
you do and she was like you know I'm an
apothecary coach and I do this and this
and the Divine Chrysalis and that that
and then it was all of this stuff
and I said shifra
I don't want to steal your joy
because I know that you're passionate
about what you do
but if you can't explain what you do
within 15 seconds
you will reach point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero one percent of the
people that's in that specific field
so being able
to communicate what you do
in a very simple way
that's another one and this is when I
said
I teach people how to come back home to
themselves through their inner child
of course
I'm a very deep mother effer I'm very
super deep
you know the people they're like man you
remind me of like Tony Robbins and I was
like yo I'm more like Harry Potter like
I'm way more Harry Potter when people
come to my containers they're like yo
this is the closest thing to Hogwarts oh
my goodness but if I went out there and
it's like yo I teach people magic and I
open up your Divine channels to so
ancient and ancestral wisdom can come
through and as you're a channel and
you're grounded the 400 000 people that
died just so you can be here your
ancestors whose DNA is encoded inside of
your body and they whisper great secrets
in your ears as long as you have deep
trust if I were to say that
every time out
there wouldn't be 2 000 people who just
signed up for my membership in one day
that wouldn't have happened but you know
what people want
they want simple
and for all the people that are really
smart
simple
because trying to teach
trigonometry to babies who don't know
the ABCs is the death of your business
before it even gets going
you must know how to translate
to the masses
if you want to reach the masses
people's language is the very thing that
takes them out
is the very thing that takes them out
of being able to truly Express their
genius in a way where it lands on the
people that you're wanting to reach
lead them into the door then show them
the rest of the mansion
so I tell people I have a retreat called
awaken the artist Within
and I attract Founders and coaches and
moms and dads and and CEOs and nine to
five people they're like oh I want to
wake in my inner I thought we were just
gonna get paint well a lot of people
don't don't even read the copy
but I created a retreat called awaken
the artist Within
laughs
and then they come in
and they're like
oh my God
I didn't know I was holding on to this
trauma
thing that was blocking me from having
intimacy with my husband
and why did it come out why because I
want you to have natural and genuine joy
in your life well the only way to do
that is to have an open pathway so if
there's any like kids store negative
impact inside of their nervous system
from when they were five well if you
want to have genuine fun whatever's in
the way is going to come out
this is what happens at my Retreats but
if I was to go out and say hey I'm gonna
trigger all of your wounds and the
person that molested you and all this
other stuff is going to come up
maybe 10 people like the most hurt
people that just like
that probably doesn't get anything done
that probably don't have religious they
would show up for that
that's not what I communicate
I know how to effectively translate a
message
that gets the part of you
that you haven't yet given a voice
that you most likely don't have support
with
that gets the part of you to wake up
your Spidey senses and be like oh
that could be the coach for me you're
damn right because I'm speaking to that
part of you
and then they come next you know there
are 60 people sold out next one 60
people sold out it's like now and this
is without paid ads this is without a
major celebrity shouting me out listen
you bait a fish with what a fish wants
you don't fish with aluminum can it
wants a juicy worm
okay the next one is knowing your
audience one time I was uh born and
raised in Houston Texas and I come from
the music industry and I used to sing
music that's very similar to Bruno Mars
before Bruno Mars came out and I had a
song called Mr ordinary and it was like
a blend of like r b and pop and it was
very like happy go lucky friendly and
there was this like gangster rap
Festival concert and I knew the DJ and I
told the DJ and I was like I said put me
on stage it was like man I just I wanna
I wanna sing a song he was like Aaron
not your audience
he was telling he's literally told me
you don't want to go on this stage
because it's not your audience
it's like
shooting killing gold teeth everything
he's like Aaron not your audience I'm
wearing like tight pants and like in a
checkered shirt with a with a fun bow
tie and I had my hair and and an
afro-like twisties he's like Garen
that's not what you want to do
and I didn't listen
I didn't listen so I was like no man
that's messed up you're not gonna put me
on stage because like you've got to know
your audience is not your audience
yes carrying a a Harry Potter wand
not your audience and it was 5 000
people you know what I did I was like
man oh man and I kept trying to push it
because I thought I knew better and I
didn't know my audience so guess what I
went up on stage when they're just
hearing a specific type of sound
that was all unhealthy
and I'm like I wake up in the morning
feeling so free stretch it up in the
yard and I cracked my feet and put on my
house shoes and go and brush my teeth
that's my ordinary ordinary I jump in
the shower just to start a new bumping
Marvin Gaye's album so part of my groove
I be singing in the Washington I'm
singing songs like that and I saw it all
the way in the back five thousand people
they were like Boo oh get the F off the
stage and next thing you know within
five minutes they're throwing
stuff at me they're throwing cans and
I'm like I'm getting booed
off the stage
in my own hometown
and that was the first and last time
I ever not knew who my audience was and
who I was speaking to
all I needed to see was that when you're
speaking to the wrong audience they do
not respond in the way that you want to
respond
I know
ninety percent of my audience is
powerful driven women
so I'm not going to be speaking like
this very masculine man
to 90 percent women who want to be
spoken with who want to be led in a
healthy way where I'm not trying to get
in their pants or take anything from
them they want to feel safe they want to
feel seen they want to feel heard they
want to feel acknowledged they want to
feel like they mattered and they want
they want to be in a safe environment so
guess what safety is my number one
priority which is why it becomes this
space inside of my Retreats they come
they're like I've never felt so safe not
even with my husband not even with my
partner I've never shared this with
anybody before I just feel so safe with
you
so I speak into the safety
that's knowing my audience
and I also am a co-founder of empowered
Brotherhood one of the largest men's
group here in Austin well guess what
I'm not speaking that into that
I'm embodying a healthy masculine man
who's happily married and when I speak
I'm speaking from a lens of being an
example from the kind of uh man that
most of us never saw when we were little
kids
so by being that person
and bringing that aspect that's the
language that comes out of my mouth
that's the posting that I do so if you
don't know that specific language of who
you're talking to
that's why they don't come and then a
lot of times people are like
my message is for everybody you'll shoot
yourself in the foot
every time
everybody can come but if you become the
kind of person it's like oh my message
is for everybody
you'll be talking to nobody
and I really want you to write this down
because this is
people don't want to get this one
this is one of them Evan Carmichael type
nuggets he didn't give me that it's
something I had to learn the hard way
but this is something you really want to
get
if you're one of those people where you
say my message is for everybody
you'll be talking to nobody
but if you Niche it
if you look at the scope of your
business or what you're trying to do or
the business that you're trying to
create and every time you make a post
you've got pregnant moms
are moms who are about to have a baby
responding to 90 percent
craft your message to them
because there's more where they came
from they just need they need a voice
all you have to do is just look at your
social media right now and just look at
the comments
you look at the comments there will be a
clear winner
more men more women UH 60 year olds like
really look and see who's naturally
responding to your stuff
and whoever is naturally responding to
yourself
there is something that you're saying in
that post
that's baiting the fish
you're giving them the kind of worm that
they want
and if you're seeing one of something
and ten of another thing
don't keep doing the message that's
speaking to the one person
do the message that's speaking to the 10
people that's like oh my God I follow
all your stuff and here's what I say and
this is really important
when people keep they're like oh you
really changed my life what about it
changed your life ask those questions
and this is when you engage with the
people who reach out to you
that really impacted me and there's like
five dads in a row
there's a friend that I work with you
know he does a movement called front row
dads
he's got nothing but dads and then he
hire you know he brought me in to come
speak at his in his front row dad's
Mastermind
I didn't go in there and then speak
about being a mom
I went in there and speak about how I
messed it up horribly with my first
daughter who's 21
and I'm I'm 43 now about to be 44 and
how I have my first daughter now and the
things that I've learned in the 20-year
Gap every single man in that room was
just bawling and crying
that's knowing your audience
so niching down
and having a message
for the people who are naturally
responding that like the there's there's
always going to be a clear winner
and if you can
give it a direction your the way in
which you're speaking the words that
you're coming out you'll get more of
those people
so the next one
is having a vision and being able to
communicate that vision
here's what that looks like
you can't hit a Target you don't have
some really talented people out there
without a vision they're like man I just
feel stuck yeah because you ain't going
nowhere
you ever been on a treadmill this is why
I don't do treadmills I don't want to
keep running and then perpetuating not
going anywhere for the sake of losing
weight
that's why I need to get outside I need
to see feel different difference feel
the progress next thing you know five
miles out five miles in
it's like I need to see that progress
but I know the direction that I'm headed
you know you get on a treadmill you're
like
I'm going here
so what you train is
here doing a lot of work and still being
in the same spot I don't think anybody
get this I might listen I'm gonna give
you all the freaking cheat codes
all the cheat codes
all right so this Vision very important
and knowing how to communicate the
vision
when I first started the awakened artist
within retreats
and then I did the name of my company is
called artist power
at the end of that retreat
I shared with them
five years out
and these are people who paid five
thousand dollars
to be at my retreat these are people who
paid right I shared with them in a very
intimate setting
y'all
we're listen to my language whether it's
one fifty or one thousand
we are a part of something really big
and I want to thank you
for trusting in yourself
to join me on this journey there's
nothing about I
or I can see myself and I'm gonna be
here and no I'm literally using the
words we
we are creating a five 150 million
dollar company within five years imagine
if you could have been a part of Apple
when it first started
I'm literally telling this to students
inside of my container imagine if you
could have been a part of Apple when it
first started
imagine the opportunities that could
have opened up
with those who helped grow
the container
and so I want to let you guys know
five years out 150 million dollar
company
there's gonna be the need to potentially
have more people in their skill sets
don't think that I'm not gonna pull
directly from the community
with those who are bought in I literally
watched almost every single person
see themselves
as a part of the movement
five years from now
so what they did was they imprinted
five years
I'm a part of something based off of a
vision that I created
that was so authentic and this that was
so real I didn't say follow me for five
years we are creating something
big
this is our movement
I have a vision
that this artist power that wakes up all
the because adults are deteriorated
children that wakes up all the kids that
are inside of adults and allows them to
live from the inside out and actually
have joy in their life that's what
you're a part of
that's what you're a part of
and I'm watching their eyes like
I was like I can see this being some
form of curriculum that goes inside of
Children's Schools something that they
can actually take with them into
adulthood
I've never used square root since I
learned it so I'm communicating this
and the second I say there's going to be
artist Power Kids Camp
our part is artist Power Kids division
I saw all the moms and somebody else
that's been a counselor they're like
bawling I said that's what you're a part
of
how can I be more involved
and so you know what that same Core
Group
when I launched
two days ago literally
it's a thousand dollars for the year
I launched two days ago
2 000 people registered
at a thousand dollars in one day
but guess what
it wasn't my launch
those beginning people
I made them ambassadors
and I said you guys if you're open
I'd love to gift you a free one-year
membership in the artist power
for your service in supporting this
group going to the next next next next
next
videos so now it came from Garen
promoting it
to 60 other people
promoting the entire movement which
created 7 2 000 people enrolled
in one day at a thousand dollars you do
the math
this my friend
is what I wanted to share with you it's
not a lot
it's a little
things that when applied can create a
massive impact in your version of
massive impact because it doesn't have
to look like mine and here's the last
thing
and I got this from a great mentor of
mine Bruce Lee
bewata my friends
you must become formless when the waters
in the river and there's a big rock the
water doesn't say there's a big rock and
just freezes my friend what it does is
it's formless and it becomes shapeless
and it and it shapes around the water
and then it goes on the path that it's
always
when you are creating your practice
when you are being a coach when you are
running your business
it will never go exactly as planned and
people are so stuck
on controlling it well that's not the
way it didn't go is playing they get all
bent out of shape
well what if what is trying to be
planned
is beyond the human context and it's
actually trying to take you 10 times
further
but if you're if you you are in the
actually in the way of the great Muse
trying to work itself into your life my
mom used to always have this saying and
I was trying to get my daughter back she
was like Garen just do your part and God
will handle the rest just do your part
though
so here's what I want to share with you
when you become formless now this is
we're getting a little into a little um
Harry potter-esque
we are 75 water
85 water in your brain
you have 70 trillion cells in your body
all of the all of it is surrounded by
water and internally is all water
and guess what
do you think it's a coincidence that
it's 75 water in the world
so maybe that big old Universe out there
just might be a reflection of that big
old Universe in here and when you become
formless you actually tap into Nature's
resources than anything that is a part
of nature
benefits
from Nature's resources which is always
producing which is always duplicating
which is always restoring itself
there is
a universal intelligence
that makes the flowers grow
and whatever's inside of you is the same
thing
that makes the flowers grow
so when you allow
this is not a forcing you don't force
the hair out of your head you don't
force the baby out of the womb you don't
force the trees to grow there is a
patience
which is one of the highest forms of
leadership
there is a patience
that goes along
with the natural order of life
and when you align yourself in that
frequency
you benefit from all that has created
the planets the Stars the moon land
grass water everything you benefit from
the same power
my friends
that is your artist power
if you apply
these five or six things some of y'all
got like 20 things like oh my God oh my
God oh my God listen
focus on two or three
and I'm not talking about kinda it's
like we'll see we'll try it a time or
two this is not a try it type thing it's
not a diet
people treat new things like a diet they
treat change like a diet
I'll try it for 30 days no no it's a
lifestyle I got my start 10 years over a
decade in health and wellness and
the people who got the best results
is who treated this this change like a
lifestyle change they're like well you
know some people like I lost 35 pounds
and then I gained it back these products
don't work no here's what like the
products work people don't work
what you did is you went back to the
same foods that gained the 35 pounds so
you treated it like a diet but the
reason why I could lose 35 pounds
put on 19 pounds of muscle take my body
fat from 16.4 percent down to six
percent and maintain that over a decade
is because I decided this is my
lifestyle I lived 32 years with the type
of foods that my mom fed she didn't know
any better because all she knew was
fatty fried and southern cooking and the
bacon double cheeseburgers was great and
me at 40 pounds overweight and even and
breathing and I can't keep up with my
daughter that's a problem for me
so gummy bears was a lifestyle somebody
was like you may have to drink these
shakes oh my God like I don't want to do
this for the rest of my life well you're
50 years old and you've been eating
pizza and drinking wine and alcohol for
35 years
but you're complaining
about one day of having something that
will actually work in your life
homie you got it backwards
the cemetery is not where you see the
most dead people it's where you walk
around every day and you see something
that's died inside of people
well hey my friends
whatever life you're wanting to come
into
treat it like a lifestyle and approach
it the same way that you brush your
teeth every day
same way you take a shower for some of
you every day
you take a shower so you clean every day
you brush your teeth so you have the
hygiene every day
you do it for 10 days I mean you do it
for 10 years and then you stop for five
days what happens your breath funky
why because it's meant for you to do
every day
so if you really want to be a coach
you beat on your craft every day you
become excellent not just talented but
skilled
and this is the final one
become skilled in your craft
there's a lot of people who are talented
and there's a lot of people with no
Talent who are skilled and they go
further than the people who are just
talented
but if you're talented
and skilled
that's the separation from everyone else
as a speaker
I am extremely talented and I am very
skilled because I beat on my craft every
single day
this
will be some very powerful ingredients
that you add
and let that be the foundational piece
that holds your business
that holds your family that holds your
marriage let this
who you are inside of this conversation
as you turn it into a lifestyle and not
a diet something you try but something
that you actually live
that will be the difference and that
will be the separation and that's why
you become a magnetized type person and
you can walk into any room and all of a
sudden people like
who's that
it's because of how you live
and it there's something that comes
through you
that wakes up people who are not living
like that because they were like damn I
I want whatever that is
and that is a person who knows themself
knows where they're going and when they
speak they speak with reverence and
conviction because their energy is not
scattered in a thousand other places
I'm going to be doing this
until the day that I physically have my
last breath but because of the billions
of people that will have been impacted
I will live forever through those
impacts the one thing that Evan had
given to me
show what you do show your value
Evan's going to live forever
why
because what I've learned is the
greatest way to say thank you
to someone who
gives
and supports you
come back with how much you change your
life so Evan brother there's millions of
people who are being impacted right now
because of what you
selflessly
gave to me
you now get access to live forever
I love you brother thank you for the
word and guys did I mentioned that
garen's also a phenomenal storyteller
uh
is there somebody that we can uh call on
Zane is is one of our first members and
always kicks us off so why don't we
bring up Zen Gary how you doing man man
I'm absolutely fabulous bro everything
you said had such an impact on me um
just how you communicate from your heart
your soul people can tell they can feel
it they can see it that you are living
in your purpose
and you have so much passion for it
um so there's so many so many takeaways
but here's my big questions most artists
most creators speakers coaches
um they're not good at the business side
of things
how did you shift because you are like
the epitome of an artist
how did you shift your mindset
um to the business side and get to the
premium High ticket and super high
ticket offers what was that process like
what's your framework how did you get
there I want y'all to write this down
make your old heart your new easy
it's the it's the process of
breakthrough in the process of growth
otherwise that's going to be a book of
mine old hard new easy I just recently
of the person who spent forty thousand
dollars to be inside of my leadership
Mastermind
I have I was toying with the idea of
doing an apprenticeship program
and the second I was on a call with her
she was like what's an apprenticeship
program
and I didn't have what it was but I was
just toying with the idea I didn't have
a price or anything I was like well it's
somebody that Shadows me for a whole
year and you get 12 one-on-one sessions
which right now to work with me it's a
hundred and forty thousand dollars for a
12 one-on-one sessions and well the
apprenticeship is like that
times 10 so it's 12 one-on-one sessions
it's two half days I have this thing
called a welcome home ceremony where I
take you in a deep deep processing six
hours at my home it's a whole entire
Journey you get two of those which those
are valued at fifty thousand dollars a
piece you get two of those you get to
come VIP to all of my Retreats two of
them as a student and then two of them
as an understudy you get to be on all of
my sales calls and on every call that
I'm on that has to do with business and
I just want to ship by the way I didn't
have any of this when I was talking
about what I was trying to do I'm just
telling her I was like downloading and
have channeling what could be
the apprenticeship program she was like
send me the link I'm ready you know like
uh I have no landing page no nothing she
was like how much is it
I didn't even have a price but I know to
work with me one-on-one is 140k for an
entire year
what came out of my mouth was 300K
the payment went through
last month
so I'm sharing this
because I would not have had the
confidence
to utter 300K for one person to Shadow
me for an entire year if I Didn't Know
My Own worth
my own value
because for the same information
I used to charge a thousand dollars to
somebody but it was based off of my own
worthiness I didn't feel myself worthy
enough to say a certain price and I
didn't believe it
so my training here's my training I have
my masters in spiritual psychology I
overcame a 12-year prison sentence and
got out in two and a half years I lived
in my car in two and a half years I
transformed that
um I didn't have my daughter for 15
years and I developed enough trust to be
able to be trusted inside of having a
relationship with my daughter I was an
uncommitted person for most of my life
now I'm in a committed marriage and I've
taken so many emotional intelligence
courses Landmark Insight Mastery and
transformational training 10-day silent
Retreats five days in the dark I've done
so much work
and I was afraid to charge somebody a
thousand dollars for the year
for the depth of wisdom
and knowledge that I had that I knew
could shift and alter their life forever
and I was like a thousand dollars
so it comes down
to the belief that you have in yourself
so
I had the skill set
but I didn't have the belief set I I
felt myself unworthy so where did I
start I started small
so my very first Retreat VIPs were five
thousand in general was 2500 and I was
reaching I was like
I was it was it was like one of those
breaths
and then when it filled up in two weeks
I was like
I might as well make the next time
rule B 5000.
and then VIP be ten thousand
and it filled up in three weeks 55
people boom and I was like what
I might as well have some offers that
are like fifteen thousand twenty five
thousand and I made four offers inside
of The Last Retreat which was to come to
my home and do that welcome home
ceremony that's often offered at fifty
thousand I baked that inside of an offer
for the retreat if you you get the VIP
plus the welcome home ceremony normally
it's fifty thousand but if you get this
inside of that it'll be twenty five
thousand I had four offers ten minutes
bam they got it bam bam and 10 minutes
that was a hundred thousand dollars I
was like I might as well create
the leadership program I didn't start
with that I started at the level of my
belief and then I when it became easy
I created another heart
until that belief came easy and then I
created another hard
well guess what
the 300 thousand you know the the
leadership program right now is they're
going to Tweet uh 12 weeks in leadership
Mastery learning all these instincts
about leadership because a lot of people
who lead followers with a business Rises
and falls on them well I've been a deck
I've been in a uh in leadership in it
for a decade and I've been leading
leaders who create and develop other
leaders so I can literally leave a
business and it's still rise based off
of how I groom and developed leaders
inside of a business well I realize that
your favorite coach's favorite coach
wanted something like that
they're in my program and it's a higher
ticket but it's also per somebody who
doesn't have issues with money
so that confidence in myself and I was
like wait a second
I'm very skilled at leading leaders I
don't have to think about how to do it
I've got a decade over a decade of
experience
so guess what
the entry level was fifteen thousand but
if you want to go to the retreat in
Tulum plus the leadership program 25
000. and if you want a six hour
thing about your business forty thousand
that thing with that thing sold out like
bam and I was like God Lee well then the
next offer was 300K
and then somebody was like I'll take it
I was like damn
so right now I'm working on a million
dollar offer
and you know what it's called the one
and I was like God and then I just
because I I the confidence it was easy
for me to do all that but it didn't
start easy there was no way I could be
like three hundred thousand dollars for
the year if I didn't
go to elementary school middle school
high school and college in my own
worthiness
in my own confidence
so this is where you make your old hard
your new easy and then find another hard
and then make that easy and then however
long it takes is however long it takes
but that's where that comes from people
just be throwing prices out there oh you
should charge ten thousand dollars and
they don't even believe in themselves
worthy of one cent hmm that's extremely
valuable thank you so much you're so
welcome who's next amazing well hey you
pick man we got a whole bunch of hands
popping up who's you know what you know
who's standing out uh since Shaq did did
the little thing I was just like come on
bring it in yo Garen Jones it is an
honor to speak to you man what I wanted
to ask you is because you're a Kung Fu
genius and what you were talking about
earlier about tapping into that
frequency I'm a Reiki healer my name is
Shaq Wukong I'm the god hand of God Hand
Reiki and acupressure and um
I work with energy too and so honestly I
feel like as long as I practice my
authentic Kung Fu just like you were
talking about like the way to be perfect
is to be authentically yourself correct
or something to that
um
um but what I wanted to ask you is like
man
because uh damn like like I want to be
like you
it's a million dollars his new program
the one
I am the one I don't know if I got a
milli yet but um what do I want to ask
you I really just wanted to talk to you
but as far as like your journey as um
as like expressing your authenticity
because I'm in well I'm a Reiki healer
and as a Reiki healer and a Reiki master
I'm a rarity because I'm young and I'm
black I'm not an older like white woman
which is like what takes up the space so
expressing my authenticity is something
that I sort of feel a little bit weird
about but if you could just share some
advice with me on like just um not
blocking my own life to try to look a
certain way yeah I'll tell you this well
yeah what could you tell me man I too
am a black man
and
I used to ask myself why am I getting
all these opportunities
that a lot of people it didn't matter
what color was getting and I was like
because I did not allow myself to see
myself as any kind of victim
or any kind of
when I'm in
my channeling
it's not man channeling it's not black
man channeling
I'm
simply a Divine Channel who happens to
be a black man but before that is the
channel
which much must be used for information
so look at a channel like
a water hose
if you tie a knot in a water hose you
got 600 pounds of water pressure
no matter how much water you have if you
turn that water on little drops of water
are coming through because there's a
knot
but when you just allow yourself to be
an open Channel then you can be used for
the information that wants to come
through so let's just say and I don't
know I know a lot of people they're not
in in the belief of
um having extra help from maybe your
guides or your Angels or please speak to
me as spiritually as you can like it is
weird as you can bro because it's not
weird
in my in my belief in my belief
I want you to think of a pack of wolves
and one finds a carcass
and when that one finds the carcass it's
not all of them finding it at the same
time
uh then one finds the carcass and then
goes to tell the rest of them
I found food and then the rest of the
pack of wolves come I want you to think
of your ancestral lineage
who all of their DNA is encoded inside
of you
as there is someone
your grandmother your great-grandmother
is someone that is specifically designed
to support you
yes somebody who passed that's mine is
my my big mama Iona gory
there's somebody specifically designed
for everyone on this call
now
their number one job
is to see if you're ready
so that she can whisper great secrets
through you
so all these people died now when you
are closed off
when you're literally closed off and
lack of belief self-doubt all these
different things so I'm a black man and
I don't look like this and I'm a this
and right there and you're you get
caught up into these worldly traps it
literally clogs up your Channel
so what the person that is assigned to
you one of your ancestors that assigned
to you says
he's not ready
but when you are open and you are
available
and you can be used just like that wolf
that finds the carcass
that person that's assigned to you says
he's ready and then goes back to the
rest of your guides and goes back to
everyone that's assigned to your life
that could be giving you information and
says he's ready
and then that's where the ancient wisdom
flows through that's where the ancestral
wisdom flows through and all it is is
you being a Divine channel for the
wisdom so that you can be used
this transcends
any nationality any religion any color
any age it transcends all of that
it transcends but because it's part of
the universal order
it's like speaking in the language not
light language but the light comes from
energy it's the the language of energy
which produces the stars and the Sun and
the Moon and like everything you now
become a conduit from the same nutrients
that fertilizes the ground it keeps the
trees here long after we're gone
does that resonate yeah totally yeah and
uh a lot of that was like it was
basically messages that I had already
received and so basically I just got to
keep doing stuff that scares me right
because that's when Spirit hits me the
strongest is when I push myself past
that tanglement that you're talking
about so I'll put myself out there and
then once that happens is when I start
to I get the clearest messages so
basically I'll just keep on scaring
myself then
check this out
the word scare
um our language
has codes in it oh for sure the words
are the Spells So when you say do stuff
that scares me
by default you automatically start
at a disadvantage
it's
do do this stuff
that I'm called to do
you don't need to say that scares me
okay I use the wrong word because
whatever you acknowledge exists do the
stuff I'm called to do period
um
gotcha
I love you brother
love you too and now you free yourself
from being scared
so I was never scared anyway you know
what I'm saying man exactly
thank you for the question that you
asked I love it I love it I see some
coaching in action thank you Wukong
let's bring up Giovanna and see what we
got what do you got for Garen hello oh
my gosh so many light bulb moments so
many Beautiful Moments shock thank you
for asking what you responded to Shaq
really just brought everything together
for me because it's uh make your old
hard your new easy like that was just
beautiful but now it's like I have to
allow myself to be used and for me again
you all have seen my book teen anxiety
no more when you spoke about like five
years from now you want there to be an
actor's Circle for uh for children for
kids it's like how do you marry
um what you want now with what you
foresee to be a possibility and and stay
in the now stay in your lane and still
move forward without getting distracted
and being like wanting to do everything
at once so
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna have you answer
this question okay
if you put
20 address if you could put 20 addresses
in the GPS system at one time where
would you go
you did it again
we didn't go anywhere
but if you put a specific address
one specific address
it would give you five different ways to
get there
it doesn't mean that you have to have
the same address the whole time when I
was living in my car two hundred
thousand dollars in debt my two things
I want to retire my mom
and I wanted to put my daughter through
college
well
every single day that's what I was
focused on that was driving what I was
doing in 2015
I was walking on the red carpet
and I was like oh my God this is the
this is what I always envision
because when I was 14 years old I always
thought I was going to win five Grammys
and walk on the red carpet with my mom
and then and then retire her and then
all of a sudden I I had left music in
2011 and
I was in a completely different industry
but for some reason I kept the same
vision I was like I left music but for
some reason I still feel like I'm gonna
win five Grammys well still I'm gonna
retire my mom and then I'm in a
completely different industry the health
and wellness industry then they have
this thing that they do at the end of
the year called the bonus Awards which
is like our version of the the Oscars
they're like congratulations you're one
of 250 that won the bonus Awards I was
like oh man that's awesome where is it
being held they said at the same place
that they host the Grammys and I'm like
what
and then I ended up winning five Awards
that I didn't even know I was gonna win
and I'm walking with my mom
on the carpet and I was like
this is that moment
it was never about what was on the
surface
but it was the the internal feeling and
the vision because you have two sets of
sites you have eyes on the inside
my internal Vision which was connected
to my feeling
I got the feeling that I always wanted
it just showed up differently on the
surface but I stayed locked in on the
the feeling that what's having you all
over the place is you're giving yourself
and your power to all these things but
there's something
that could actually encapsulate all
those things but that something needs
all of you otherwise you're operating
from from Prism Power and Prism Power is
like a light that looks really pretty
then it splashes all over the place but
it doesn't do anything but look pretty
but if it's like one stream of light
pointed in a Direction that's the laser
beam that cuts through the deadbolt lock
and your commitment
to that one thing
is what's gonna
demagnetize all the other distractions
and if you can lock into that
it doesn't mean that you can't do
something else it means that the
universe is just trying to give you the
opportunity to see what's staying with
one thing is like so you can develop the
discipline the grit the skill set the
power I mean everything that comes with
raising a garden
and not growing fruit on other people's
trees
like this one thing and then it might
give you the skill set and the tools to
go to the next thing
Bruce Lee says fear not the man that
practices a thousand kicks fear the man
that practices one kick a thousand times
do that and do it and become an expert
at it
this is what I did with my speaking
but then when I went from that I did
the speaking then I went to coaching and
then I became an expert at that
and then I went to to healing and then I
don't say outwardly that I'm a Healer
but anybody that comes into my space
there's lots of healing and there's lots
of releases and there's lots of there's
just certain things that you don't say
outwardly but you know you got to get
them into the Mansion um get them
through the door then you show them the
rest of the Mansion wow I mean
everything resonated so much I am after
I
I am pivoting so that I can support our
youth and our teens
um based on what I learned and how I
don't want them to suffer and I want to
help them go through their teens a
little bit more gracefully based on what
I know I can give them and that's what I
do on my platform and I needed the
acting to create that platform so thank
you for helping me just stay focused
because this does feel like the next
thing for me or the thing and it's just
staying um on this track and and trust
yourself
trust in in in the feeling
and anytime you commit to something
it will always unlock the equal of its
resistance
that's that's what tests you to see if
what you want is what you really want
more Evan there's somebody that has a
burning question Jessica and Brian
everything you said resonated with who I
was when I was 16 years old and I just
preached the same stuff at our workshop
last month talking about Bruce Lee
philosophy and being like that wolf and
I had every man and every woman in that
audience crying I knew that was the
moment that was the moment it clicked in
the passion inside but the issue that
I'm having is trying to find the time to
do it because I'm raising an autistic
child and when he's in school a lot of
times 10 to 2
I'm at work outside the house so I don't
have time to do what I need to do and
I'm trying to do it with my partner
Jessica because we are basically we are
is we're dating coaches for geeks Gamers
and pop culture nerds and we want to
help them find that love within
themselves so that they can find the
dream partner
because ultimately the mission for me is
when you teach about love and help
people find love it eradicates the hate
so how do I go about finding the ideal
schedule to get that going because I
keep hearing Evan preaching about Evan
you're always preaching about schedule
schedule yeah what time do you wake up
in the morning
um usually around 7 30. what would
happen if you woke up at 4 30.
and had two and a half hours to yourself
I'd have to first of all realign my
sleeping schedule because that's usually
I'm usually working on some of the
business at night
and then sometimes like when I'm working
on Spirit just channels through me and
all of a sudden I'm just before I know
it time's gone and I'm going to bed like
around 11 30 12 o'clock at night okay
when are you the most effective
when you're about to go to sleep
usually yeah usually because Jessica's
the same way when we're first waking up
in the morning it's like brain dead have
to have a few hours to wake up and we're
trying to reorganize our time schedule
so that we're having our fun together as
a couple in the morning walk me through
your walk me through your schedule you
wake up at 7 30. okay so I wake up at 7
30. I'm getting my son ready to go to
school wait um what's the first thing
you do as soon as you wake up
first thing I do as soon as I wake up is
I thank the universe for being alive
another day okay how long does that take
at least a minute and then I'm up I get
up
and I go and get my knock on my son's
door to make sure he's awake and if he's
not awake I help my girlfriend get him
up then I head downstairs because it's
in my office I head downstairs get his
breakfast ready get him ready start
getting him prepared for school getting
his clothes lined up
since I started changing that over now
so it's lined up the night before and
then getting everything ready and then
I'm spending time with him on the couch
until he goes out the door
at around between 8 15 to 8 30.
do you have a nanny
nope
can you afford one
not yet
do you know how much nannies cost
for special needs kids from what I've
Been Told
it can be high price
so
to get somebody I mean to to get his
clothes what walk me through everything
walk me through uh walk me through what
it takes to wake him up in the morning
I got Jessica helping she's our meeting
yeah I got Jessica happened so she so
she helps take care of that so basically
it's waking him up and if he's not awake
then I have to go in his room and pull
the covers off of him so he sees the
daylight rip open his blinds so he sees
its daylight and then if I have to I put
on some positive music but I crank it up
super loud so that way he can no longer
sustain staying asleep and he gets up
some days when I get him up in the
morning he's angry as hell and some days
it's a great oh hey Dad let's go get
ready I'm ready for school kind of deal
because he loves his school so it's so
you wake up okay hold on really quick so
you wake up and you go straight to that
yep
give yourself an extra hour and a half
and wake up an hour and a half before
that
figure that one out
because if you wake up and you go
straight and literally go straight to
that
what would it be like
woke up two hours before
you had two hours every single day
for 365 days
that would require going to bed about
two hours early
how much sleep do you need
on average for me about seven hours
hey about seven hours all right cool so
do you have a personal assistant
no
other than Jessica
is your partner
yep
okay but you can also work two jobs so
I'm not cool
I'm sure there's a person
somewhere inside of your field
that can support you with emails that
can support you with screening calls
that can that can support you
um in a way that allows you to be in
your Genius
and they actually don't cost a lot
like at all
because I when I was barely making money
I was still I was like I found
somebody's like there's somebody in your
field somebody's little daughter
somebody that knows that you can just
get off the ground that can just give
you some breathing space but what I'm
hearing right now is you can never have
time that you don't create
so this is one of those things and it
may not last forever but it's one of
those things where you just figure it
out
you take care of your health you drink
plenty of water
and you figure out how you can wake up
two hours earlier
and then give yourself two hours to dial
in and focus and you give yourself two
hours for 365 days that will be the
hugest Difference by creating creating
time
I would say focused there before air
before anything or else yours is going
to get up go get up go get up go but
when you're not giving time to yourself
like real
real efficient time like my wife can't
get me before I have me
there's no person on this planet well
when my when my daughter was first born
she's on the sleep schedule now
she she was waking up at
I used to have 5 a.m dialed in then she
started waking up at like 5 a.m 5 30 5
30 a.m I was like damn I'm like
everybody's getting me before I get me
so I had to just figure it out
so guess what I was like yo I'm waking
up at 4 30. I'm just gonna figure it out
that happened to be the greatest thing
that I did I got up 4 30.
I did I do a whole thing where I I train
your life force which is the breath
inside of your body I do a whole life
Force training I have a cold plunge a
whole biohacking system I go running at
4 30 in the morning and I only breathe
through my nostrils and every three
steps I'm going two three two three for
ten straight miles but that right there
wakes me up and that's where I get all
of my downloads I mean like God is like
hey and have this and this and this and
this and this and then I come home
and then me and my wife we have the T
and then we go in there with the baby
it's because I had to create the time
the thing about it is when you wake up
early
and you're up to something big there's a
different energy inside of you so you
need you can do it off of less sleep
when you're plugged into something
bigger than when you're just plugged
into yourself it's a it's a whole
different understanding of power that
can flow through you but you need to
create more time and this is an actual
need otherwise you're going to run
eventually run yourself into the ground
and what you call your coaching practice
you're not going to have the energy to
be able to sustain for anything larger
than what you have right now and I'm
assuming there's not a lot coming in if
you can't afford for a nanny or somebody
to do that right now bro create whatever
you need to create
so that you can have that level of
support and let that be one of your whys
to create
I pay people so I can be my genius I
don't like looking at emails don't like
PowerPoints all these things if I'm not
in my genius and I'm thinking about all
these other tests somebody's getting
fired I pay people to keep me in my
genius when I'm in my genius the world
is a better place
Garen Jones ladies and gentlemen if you
want to join us in movement makers check
the link in the description below
otherwise enjoy this video right here I
think you'll love it